PlayStation VR 2 officially arrives in a
few days and ahead of the rollout
reviews have gone live a successor to
the original PlayStation VR psvr 2
combines a huge leap forward in
technology while taking a few cues from
the PlayStation 5 in its dual sense
controller so far critics have been
impressed by the elegant design of the
headset and the powerful Hardware inside
of it while psvr 2 has some incredible
Tech to Marvel at there are a few
caveats as well as reviewers have noted
Horizon call of the mountain is doing
most of the heavy lifting on the
software side of the equation while
every other game rolling out to psvr 2
over the next month consists of titles
that are currently available on other VR
Platforms in our own review Tamar
Hussein wrote quote the psvr 2 is
undoubtedly a major step forward for
PlayStation's virtual reality Ambitions
and one of the best headsets on the
market but in the ever-shifting
landscape of virtual reality its price
and current value proposition leave it
in awkward position once again over at
IGN Gabriel Moss gave the headset a 9
out of 10 and said quote with top-notch
visual quality and immersively tactile
sense controllers PlayStation VR 2
represents a Quantum Leap over its
predecessor setting a new standard for
console VR Gaming at VGC Jordan Miller
gave it a 4 out of 5 and said quote psvr
2 is an amazing headset but whether it's
worth it to the average PS5 user is yet
to be seen as despite the amazing
technology the software so far isn't
enough to convince most to run out and
buy one PlayStation VR 2 Launches on
February 22nd and will cost 550 dollars
is that too much money are you getting
one let me know in the comments but psvr
2 isn't the only thing being reviewed
right now Omega forces Monster Hunter
inspired wild Hearts is just around the
corner and the reviews are looking
pretty good Richard Wakeling reviewed
the game for Gamespot and said whatever
weapon you choose Wild heart's action is
thrilling if familiar there's a palpable
sense of weight behind each weapon swing
and you need to consider when to attack
so you're not locked in an animation
when you're forced to roll out of danger
IGN push square and Destructoid gave the
game an 8 as well meanwhile Games Radar
gave the game a 4 out of 5 and said
quote wildhearts is a worthy competitor
to Monster Hunter boasting brilliantly
creative weapons and fearsome beasts to
match discovered only by an infuriating
camera Omega Force definitely avoids
devling into colonist themes and wild
Hearts is all the better for it I have
the trial of the game currently
downloaded on PC but I haven't tried it
yet what do you think of the game let me
know in the comments and we'll see you
again tomorrow
foreign